have a seat sure it is an honor to meet
you sir
we did not get to meet backstage but
it's nice to see you congratulations on
Mad Max and tell us why what was your
decision to sort of revisit the
franchise after all this time
the story popped in my head and just
wouldn't get away like an imaginary
friend that just wouldn't go away and I
always you know I love chase movies I
think they're the kind of purest form of
cinema that's where the film language
started I wanted to make one long
extended chase and to see what we could
pick up about the characters in the
story on the way does it feel
did it feel familiar to be back in this
world or did it feel new to you what was
the after all this time what I did what
did it seem like both ways it was
certainly familiar but a lot of time has
passed the technology's changed it was a
real opportunity to go back and revisit
it so yeah it was a really interesting
thing to do crazy but interesting so
talking about like a Tom Hardy and
Charlize the Nicholas Hoult like when
you're building the cast what is it that
you're trying to accomplish with these
actors well you know people often say
that 75% of your job is done as a
director when in the casting so it's
very specific to characters obviously I
was waiting for someone like Tom Hardy
to come along
it has all those other qualities and
Charlize when eventually I hope you get
to see the movie you'll know there's
certain dimensions of Charlize which
exactly fit the character of furiosa so
and the same in many ways with
with ethnic health yeah so that applies
to all of its in that but by the way can
I say this is my first time and I'm
sorry to do this I've got a family at
home and they don't believe I'm here are
you gonna call them no no no I'm not
gonna call them they'll be amazing if
you call them I'm gonna take a picture
of you in front of it
I got a bunch there that's amazing
fantastic you know does she
and I was you know I grew up in a small
rural town and I was the kid who always
got into trouble for drawing cartoons
and and and and reading too many comic
books and going off to insane termini
movies and so on it never dreamed
something like this with it would be the
case the people come all around the
world there's someplace like this so
this is a show me so this is kind of a
spiritual home ground it's amazing I
mean it's like yeah there's that when
you're a kid and then all the grown-ups
are like that's never gonna lead to
anything and then later we realize that
the generation before us is stupid and
that's what for me it was like your
video games are giving anything like
shut up I'll show you
but you Moran an e W that this film you
did like 3500 storyboards or something
to put this with this film together yeah
that's right Chris
I actually was determined not to do the
conventional thing and that was ride the
screenplay so he basically boarded the
whole film as a one long comic book and
it was certainly 500 panels oh my god
and but so because it's a there's not
many words spoken in the movie people
only speak when they have to and I
wanted to try to tell the story as best
as possible just in pictures and it's
pretty interesting I work it's really
really really great storyboard artists
and and comic artists themselves Brendan
McCarthy within my co-wrote this right
piece mark 16:2 Peter pound and we just
sat in a room and these panels came and
the story came and that's for the most
part a love of the movie we shot
excellent by the way we're gonna take
questions in a few minutes so if you
have some questions get ready for George
so take us back to 1979 what is that how
is the process change for you I mean
when you're when you're making we're
making Road Warrior then obviously what
are you what are you building on like
what was what was the initial idea well
you know put simply it really is an
opportunity to go back and tell a very
very simple allegory they kind of like
westerns on wheels and even though it
said in the future like 45 years in the
future you're able to go back to a much
more elemental behavior more medieval
and so on where there's no rule of law
there's no honor basically people are
surviving and doing it they can so in
that way it's very very much like those
those westerns are very spare and and
clear movie and you can't get away from
all the clover and yeah and if it's some
reason I just love wreaking Carson and
who knew that Mel Gibson would literally
turn into Mad Max at one point we all
asked the question what is charisma why
are there people set apart as kind of
movie stars and I think it's part of it
is they have that internal tension on
the one hand they're extremely lovable
and accessible on the other hand there
is an element of danger
yeah and that applies I think to
virtually every charismatic person that
strange mixture and and it I'm
simplifying it I can't keep it that
simple and you know and I must say Tom
has that quality is extremely lovable
and has another quick another quality
that is kind of like watching a big wild
animal you just don't know what they're
gonna do next and I think that's the
paradox is the big it is is one of the
elements of charisma and so yeah I've
been lucky I've worked with some
wonderful actors were you surprised when
the film came over to the states in 1980
and became the
a complete smash success yeah I'm
surprised whenever this if it says you
work so hard in the movie and you look
at it you put it out there you have no
idea how it's going to be received and
you know had you told me when we did I'd
be making another one all these years
later I would have just would not have
believed you I would have thought you
were crazy
so obviously the film relies heavily on
the vehicles so tell us a little about
the designing the vehicles and and what
your vision was for that well one of the
key things as I said before if if from
next Wednesday all the bad things we
hear in the news started to have an
economic collapse and so on and so on
and and you go forward about 45 years
all the remaining artifacts including
the vehicles would be those that you
could sort of resurrect so we women so
one of the things we have to do with all
that designers and so on to say okay you
can only base it on on real vehicles and
those more likely to survive so if
anything with too much technology
anything with too many computers and
electricals and so on it has to be you
know older technology and so that that
was the kind of rule that we use so when
you see the vehicles you'll recognize
the ABCs excellent I think we have a
question yeah hey man what's your name
my a my what's your question yeah my
question was just it's been so long
since the last movie in the franchise
came out and I was just wondering has
your life experience since then
everything that's uh you've done has
that influenced the way you've
approached this and you taken a
different approach with this film than
you have with the previous that is a
good question Michael no that's a great
question
to answer truthfully I'll have to be
very revealing I would say yeah I hope
you know I really think what happens is
you got to put all your skills and
wisdom into your work it's gonna bleed
you dry and you put it up there some now
for better and for worse and
I hope matured I I mean you know I'm one
of those people quite fascinated about
how the world evolves I think we all are
and some of it's incredibly inspiring
and some of its kind of scary and I you
know and you try to get that into your
work I look back at the old films and I
can't I can barely remember how I
understood how to make them I was that I
was working out of instinct and when I
got to this movie and you end up going
out there for over a hundred days
crashing vehicles in an African desert
and stand out to stand after stunts with
with in a lot of cases with cast doing
the stunts you kind of lose any sense of
yourself and you're just working off any
snake than God so what so you know how
much that has changed other remains to
be see I feel like maybe thanks for the
question yeah thanks Mike I feel like
before we get to the next question what
you were just talking about might be
better reflected and footage did you
bring some footage that you would like
to show yeah we did we did bring some
footage it's the first time anybody in
this world has seen any fury road what
can you tell us about Charlie's is a
character oh she's I can tell her yeah
you her name in character
furiosa Imperator furiosa okay she's she
is the chief of a boss of a war ii that
the big war ii which races across the
wasteland and there and max the guy who
just wants to be himself he thinks
that's the best way to survive get swept
up in in their story excellent sir
let's have a couple more questions hi
what's your name my name is Joe b-joo so
if I remember correctly Mad Max was made
for a budget about four hundred thousand
dollars back in 79 yeah
Hollywood was a very different beast at
that point it is completely different
now you've developed a iconic character
I now know you want to tell a completely
different story are you able to do that
in this environment or as Tina Turner
said do we really need another era well
actually she said we don't need another
hero but you know so I think what Joe
was trying to say now is like how you
know did you find in this in this
Hollywood climate was it was it an
easier film to make or was it more
enjoyable or less enjoyable what was the
experience the first one the first movie
Mad Max was the toughest movie I ever
had to make the budget was low but more
importantly I really didn't know it was
the first movie set I've ever been on
except for a short I've made so I didn't
know what to expect by the time I got
here I know you a lot more you know what
to expect
but basically I'm definitely able to
make the movie I want to make the you
know we've been making movies now with
Warner Brothers for since that first Mad
Max and they've been you know they allow
the film makers their process and and
that this is definitely the film I want
to make you know the movie in my head
and this has always been the case is
never quite the movie that you get out
there 100% but this is very high up
there very high percentage if it's
realized and I'm you know very happy
that but you're absolutely right the
world has changed the world has changed
radically I mean with very first Mad Max
we did that video split we didn't know
we took a it took a over a week before
we saw our dailies you had no idea what
is each shot now you see it immediately
so you can be more refined and so on and
now you've got and also I believe we as
audiences have changed we're able to
apprehend cuts much much faster then
then we have been in the past if you
look at some of the movies back then
they are rhythmically slower and if if
you if you think of movies like music
the tempos have increased and we're able
to read even from being little babies
and little kids a lot lot soon quicker
so things have changed excellent hey
what's your name my name is Andy great
to meet you number one a lot of us have
been waiting over 30 years for a film
like this to come out so thank you very
much when I heard it was being made I
actually had this jersey made and Steven
eclipsed kind of changed my question but
there elements of the last two films
within fury road and I just want to know
tonally how does fury road think within
regional trilogy I'd say I'd say it's
close to Mad Max 2 or road warrior
simply because it happens over a short
period of time over a few days and it as
I said is an extended chase and that
sort of totally what Mad Max too was Mad
Max 1 was more of the story you know
family story and so on Mad Max 2 was a
hybrid of those so I'd say it's
definitely closer to that excellent
thanks man all right great so movie
comes out in May next year where are you
in the process right now
well I get on a plane tomorrow night and
tell people about what I've experienced
in the comic-con I couldn't believe when
we drove in people and so on
I'll take those memories back home I go
straight into the recording session Tom
who's recording with a big Orchestra on
Tuesday and it's Tom Hulkenberg is doing
the store junkie XL really strong school
and so that's what we're doing and
pretty soon we'll be mixing it together
and tidying up a few things and we'll be
bye-bye to fury road for me and then
it's just sort of winding down can you
tell us about any of the other
characters anything else we can expect
to see in the film oh god there's a lot
of characters the interesting thing Maz
will come out with it now the you saw
the guy :
parrot uh sorry immortan joe the guy
with long hair and a mask that's Hugh
keays-byrne who two thirty years ago
played the Turkana and died at the end
of that movie and it was great I thought
if you're in a mask you know people were
confuse it so so Hugh keays-byrne close
the the important the abort 10 Joe
excellent
so listen congratulations I think
everyone here is super excited to see
fury road and we have to wait a little
bit longer but everything you've shown
here is incredible and it's been
wonderful to meet you and I wish you the
best of this movie I know we're super
excited to see it and a huge hamper
George Miller please make the team today
you